les élections en algérie en fin
d'après-midi abdelaziz bouteflika a
accepté la présidence algérienne il a
considéré avoir la légitimité populaire
avec pour ce scrutin boycotté par les
six autres candidats près de 74% des
suffrages à une participation supérieure
à la moitié des inscrits des chiffres
difficilement vérifiables reportage
gérard québec bruno girodon
fraîchement élu abdelaziz bouteflika
fait sa première apparition publique cet
après midi une cohue indescriptible
entre son service d'ordre et les
journalistes
tout cela dans une grande improvisation
est d'abord ils s'inquiètent de
l'absence de sonorisation le tapotement
des doigts sur les micro comme houari
boumédiène dont il fut ministre et à qui
il voudrait tant ressembler son élection
contestée il en rejette la critique d'un
revers de manche
que ce soit ici ou ailleurs que ce soit
ici en france mensuel 74%
c'est quand même pas respectable je n'y
touche l'homme ce monde tour à tour
menaçant puis séducteur il passe
d'ailleurs dans registre à l'autre en
quelques secondes son credo le
nationalisme algérien avec comme
corollaire la critique de l'ancien
colonisateur la france justement le
ministère français des affaires
étrangères le quai d'orsay a fait part
de sa préoccupation après l'élection
l'homme réplique fermement je voudrais
bien peau qui vole ses deux sauts et aux
plus faibles de loi les affaires de
l'algérie et je voudrais dire en même
temps que je n'ai pas été
particulièrement heureux de voir le
cadeau c'est le même que dossier se
préoccuper en disant qu'il prenait acte
savez ce que je veux lui
de la démission du président algérien
cette forme de tutelle cette forme de
blocs et or à cette forme de souraide
illimité est absolument inacceptable
avec moi de la sueur peuvent être de
choix et de qualité
je suis prêt à aller aussi loin que les
français le souhaitent mais je ne suis
prêt à accepter ni tutelle ni leçon
morale ni préoccupations ni jugement de
valeur de quelques personnalités
politiques que ce soit officielle ou non
officiel particulièrement applaudi cette
partie de son discours montre bien que
l'appel au nationalisme a aussi une
fonction de politique intérieure là
encore l'homme se veut l'héritier de
houari boumédiène